yeah that's a star is born actor
shangela hitting the high notes in
shallow
[Music]
the both of them are really great actors
so when you see them on screen they had
this like kinetic energy that you're
just like oh my god I live for them I
live for their love but they're
professionals and you know what they
just of course made everyone else feel
like you know what if they're shoot at a
hundred I better do the same thing now
that Lady Gaga and Bradley Cooper are
both single it begs the question does
shangela see potential for them as a
couple a star is born at the root is a
passionate love story and these two
people deserve love so wherever they
find it I'm like hallelujah better get
it and please let me know next I would
be poor Bradley Cooper and Lady gaga
finding love wherever they want to find
it because I live for both of them I
just want to catch the bouquet
Gaga if you throw in the bouquet at
whatever weight you have to have maybe
throw it to me okay
tt caught up with shangela at variety
and Mercedes Benzes power of pride event
in New York City
I have on rainbow appropriate undies but
you don't want to see those tonight but
just know I'm feeling the pride from
inside out I'm thrilled and honored and
excited for this list first of all its
power fry and I've always been a parsnip
dog it's so important to have pride for
who you are to be unafraid to live out
your life out loud and proud your best
most authentic life and as part of a
member of the LGBTQ community it's so
important that there's a lot of people
you know I have not always been as
accepting of our community and believed
in the quality of us all so it's great
to have this list and also the beyond
this list with so many amazing people
present my homegirls on it says Lena
that Lena wave is on this list the
Fearne Cotton's on this list you know
Bobbi Campbell Gaga's managers on this
list so it's really cool the drag star
shared his biggest allies who he says
shaped who he is today I had three very
important people in my life
what first and foremost my mom has
always been the greatest ally for me
when I came out as the young gay person
she was like right there in my corner
like all right baby
what do I need to learn what do I need
to do so she's always been in my corner
my biggest cheerleader I love my mom in
addition I Jennifer Lewis an actress and
great friend of mine who has inspired me
so much both with her onstage and
offstage self I'm like whoo hallelujah
by Lewis and then the final will be
RuPaul someone who has created so many
great opportunities who saw something in
me at a very young drag age that I
didn't even really see much in myself
but now I'm standing here and I will
always be super thing
you